AND DANA PERINO, "THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
IS LIFE WORTH LIVING WITHOUT
THANKSGIVING?
AND OREGON VIOLATORS HAVE RULES
AGAINST LARGE GATHERINGS THAT
COULD FACE JAIL TIME WHERE THEY
WILL BE GATHERED IN LARGE GROUPS
IN JAILS WITH OTHER VIOLATORS.
>> FOR THE LAST EIGHT MONTHS
I’VE BEEN ASKING OREGONIANS TO
FOLLOW THE LETTER AND THE SPIRIT
OF THE LAW, AND WE HAVE NOT
CHOSEN TO ENGAGE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE NO OTHER
OPTION.
>> Greg: NO OTHER OPTIONS, AND
ALSO JAIL TIME WHILE SOME JUST
FREAK OUT.
>> FIRST OF ALL, LET’S TRY NOT
TO BE OBNOXIOUS INOFFENSIVE IN
YOUR TONE.
IF BY THE STATES NUMBERS YOU
HATE 3%, THE SCHOOLS CLOSE.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
THEY ARE NOW GOING TO OVERRIDE.
WE DID IT ALREADY.
THAT IS THE LAW IN OUR RED ZONE.
FOLLOW THE FACTS.
WELL, THEN YOU ARE CONFUSED.
>> PARENTS ARE STILL CONFUSED AS
WELL.
>> NO, THEY ARE NOT CONFUSED,
YOU ARE CONFUSED.
READ THE LAW, READ THE LAW.
>> Greg: HE NEEDS THAT LARGE
Q-TIP TO CLEAN OUT HIS EARS.
I WONDER IF HIS BROTHER STILL
HAS IT.
PHOTOS EMERGED OF GAVIN NEWSOM
PARTYING UP ON SHUTTING DOWN.
THIS AS THE P.A. GOVERNOR ORDERS
YOU TO WEAR A MASK AT HOME.
DESPITE WITH ME, I’VE BEEN DOING
THAT FOR YEARS.
BUT THIS IS GETTING GROSS,
SERIOUSLY.
WE ARE ADULTS WHO ALREADY WORK
TOGETHER TO SAVE THE MOST
VULNERABLE LIVES.
YOU FLATTEN THE CURVE, NOT THE
POLITICIANS, YOU SAVE THE LIVES,
NOT THE MEDIA.
YOU PULLED IT OFF, NOT THEM.
IT’S HARD TO BE LECTURED BY
BOZOS WHO DID NOTHING AND IT’S
HARD TO SIT BY WHILE RULES ARE
ENFORCED DIFFERENTLY FOR
DIFFERENT PEOPLE.
IT’S ALWAYS THE WRITERS WHO
BREAK THEIR OWN LAWS FLYING OFF
TO MAUI OR FAKING QUARANTINE AND
THEN THEY WAG THEIR FINGERS AT
YOU WHO ARE THE HEROES.
THEN THEY EXCUSE THE MOB WHO
DOES NOT JUST VIOLATE SOCIAL
DISTANCING, BUT ALSO YOUR
PERSONAL SPACE.
YOUR EVENT IS THE
SUPER-SPREADER, OTHERS IS
HEROISM.
SO IT IS JAIL TIME IF YOU VISIT
GRINNING, BUT A WOMEN WHO SPITS
IN A COT FACE IS OUT IN A FEW
HOURS, HOW IS THAT NOT ASSAULT
WITH A DEADLY WEAPON?
COPS ARE EVIL, SO SPIT AWAY.
SO THE PUBLIC SHOULD BE PISSED
OFF, WE KNOW THAT IT IS FUN
BEING A TYRANT, BUT WE KNOW WHAT
TO DO.
WE DON’T WANT A RELATIVE TO DIE,
SO DON’T INSULT US BY SAYING WE
DON’T CARE.
SO MY THOUGHTS FOR THANKSGIVING
IS WHY NOT MAKE SOME SIGNS AND
CALLED A PROTEST?
TELL EVERYBODY THAT YOU ARE
SPEAKING TRUTH TO TURKEY.
WEAR A MASK AND KEEP YOUR
DISTANCE AND DO IT FOR GRANNY
NOT THE GOVERNORS.
ALL RIGHT, KENNEDY, YOU ARE THE
LIBERTARIAN IN THIS COMPANY.
IT IS AN INTERESTING CHALLENGE,
BECAUSE THIS IS REALLY WHAT
AMERICA IS.
IT IS ABOUT FREEDOM AND RISK.
GIVE ME LIBERTY OR GIVE ME
DEATH.
WE CAN HAVE BOTH.
>> Kennedy: THE IDEA THAT YOU
HAVE TO SACRIFICE FREEDOM FOR
SECURITY HAS BEEN SHOWN TO BE A
FALSE PARADIGM.
BUT JUST MAKE SOME SIGNS AND
CALL IT A PROTEST.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO FOR THE
BUSYBODIES OUTSIDE YOUR KITCHEN
WITH BINOCULARS IS JUST HOLD UP
SOME BIDEN/HARRIS PILL FINALE
AND SAY THAT WE ARE CELEBRATING
THE VICTORY.
THE VIRUS KNOWS NOT TO ATTACK
PEOPLE THAT ARE STANDING
SHOULDER TO SHOULDER CELEBRATING
A GREAT VICTORY.
BUT WE DO HAVE TO BE VERY
MINDFUL OF OUR OWN ACTIONS.
AND I THOUGHT ONCE ELECTION DAY
CAME AND WENT THAT THAT WOULD BE
THE END OF THE VIRUS BUDGET
READ, BUT IT HAS ONLY BEGUN.
AND THAT’S BECAUSE PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN POWER WHO HAVE A DIM VIEW
OF OTHER HUMAN BEINGS NOW WANT
TO CONTROL THEM MORE THAN EVER,
ESPECIALLY WITH A VACCINE ON THE
HORIZON, BECAUSE THEY KNOW WHAT
THE VACCINE THERE IS HOPE AND
THAT MEANS THAT THE DOORS WILL
BE OPEN FOR BUSINESSES, CHURCHES
AND SCHOOLS, SO THEY HAVE TO DO
WHATEVER THEY CAN TO CONCENTRATE
POWER AND THOSE COULD HAVE A
LONG-TERM BAD EFFECTS.
>> Greg: I WONDER IF ANYBODY
WILL LOOK AT A SURGE IN CASES
TWO WEEKS AFTER THE BIDEN
CELEBRATIONS?
THEY ALSO SAID, EXPERTS ARE
SAYING NO SINGING, NO LOUD
MUSIC, AND NO ALCOHOL, WHAT IS
LEFT FOR YOU?
>> Dana: I CAN’T SING AT ALL,
THE ALCOHOL THING WE WILL HAVE A
FIGHT.
BUT I WAS THINKING, IT SOUNDED
LIKE FOR ME, THE ISSUE IS
SPEAKING LOUD OR SINGING, I
LAUGH LOUD AND I ENJOY A GOOD
LAUGH, THAT’S ONE OF THE GREAT
THINGS ABOUT THANKSGIVING.
I DO THINK FOR SOME OF THESE
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN GOVERNMENT
OR -- PEOPLE WHO ARE IN POWER.
LET’S TAKE GOVERNOR CUOMO
GOVERNOR CUOMO OR KATE BROWN OUT
IN OREGON.
I DON’T HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
PAIRED I CAN ONLY TAKE CARE OF
MYSELF AND MY FAMILY AND DO THE
RIGHT THING FOR ME AND THAT IS
IT.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE A PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT FOR A REASON.
THEY GO AROUND AND THEY GIVE THE
RESTAURANTS A GRADE, AND WE NEED
THAT.
AND I ALSO DO HAVE SOME EMPATHY
FOR THESE DOCTORS AND NURSES WHO
ARE EXHAUSTED.
THEY ARE TIRED.
AND SOME OTHER THINGS, THE
HOSPITALS CAN’T HANDLE THE LOAD,
SO I UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY ARE
TRYING TO DO, BUT WHEN IT COMES
TO MAYOR de BLASIO AND
SCHOOLS, HE HAD THIS ARBITRARY
NUMBER, 3% MEANS WE SHUT DOWN
SCHOOLS AGAIN.
BUT DOES NOT TAKE INTO ANYTHING
WE HAVE LEARNED.
AND TEACHERS TO STUDENTS, SO
WHAT HE HAS DONE IS HE IS
FAILING THE STUDENTS BECAUSE HE
CANNOT COME TO AN AGREEMENT WITH
ADULTS.
AND I THINK WE WILL PAY A BIG
PRICE.
THE CHILDREN WHO ARE MISSING OUT
ON A YEAR OF SCHOOL OR MORE,
THEY ARE GOING TO TAKE A BIG
PRICE.
I JUST WENT TO MENTION ONE OTHER
THING ABOUT THAT.
A FRIEND OF MINE HAS A COLLEAGUE
THAT SHE AND HER HUSBAND BOTH
WORK, THEY HAVE A 7-YEAR-OLD SON
WHO HAS ADHD AND HAS NOT BEEN
ABLE TO GO TO IN-PERSON SCHOOL.
HE CANNOT LEARN ONLINE.
HE BASICALLY MISSED AN ENTIRE
YEAR OF SCHOOL AND HAS FORGOTTEN
HOW TO READ.
THAT SHOULD BE UNACCEPTABLE TO
ALL OF US.
>> Greg: THAT IS ANOTHER
CASUALTY, WE HEAR ABOUT DRUG
OVERDOSE, SUICIDE, DEPRESSION,
THE DELAYED EDUCATION WILL HURT
PEOPLE IN LOWER INCOME AND OTHER
BRACKETS.
THE WEALTHY WILL BE ABLE TO GET
THROUGH WITH THIS.
>> Jesse: I WILL HAVE TO BRIBE
MY CHILDREN IN A COLLEGE SOMEHOW
SOMEWAY, HOPEFULLY I CAN AFFORD
IT UNDER THE BIDEN ECONOMY.
THERE IS NOTHING THAT SAYS I
CAN’T INVITE UNCLE JIMMY OVER
FOR DESSERT.
IF AUNT SUE WHO WANTS TO BREAK
OUT INTO SONG I’M SUPPOSED TO
TELL HER THAT IS AGAINST THE
LAW?
OR I CAN’T SCREAM WHEN THE LIONS
DON’T COVER ON THANKSGIVING.
THAT’S CRAZY.
BUT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THIS
MASK WORSHIPING.
I WEAR A MASK IN MANHATTAN, BUT
IF I DON’T WASH MY HANDS OR
SOCIAL DISTANCE IN THE MASK, IT
IS USELESS.
WHERE ALL THESE LITTLE HOT SPOTS
ARE POPPING UP WHETHER IT IS
CALIFORNIA, WISCONSIN,
MINNESOTA, ILLINOIS, ALTHOUGH
STATES HAVE HAD MASK MANDATES
FIRM MONTHS AND ARE RUN BY
DEMOCRATS.
IT IS NOT THE SILVER BULLET.
THEY HAD AN OUTBREAK AT THE
MAYO CLINIC AND AT THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
THESE ARE NOT TRUMP-FRIENDLY
TERRITORIES.
THE ROYAL FAMILY, PROFESSIONAL
ATHLETES, DEMOCRATIC POLITICIANS
HAVE CAUGHT IT.
IF THERE IS ONLY SO MUCH YOU CAN
DO AGAINST A VIRUS.
THE VIRUS WILL ALWAYS WIN.
SO ANY TIME SOMEBODY, IT IS NOT
ONE POLITICIAN’S FAULT.
YOU HAVE TO LOWER THE MORTALITY
AS BEST YOU CAN AND WAIT FOR A
VACCINE AND AT THE SAME TIME YOU
HAVE TO STAY CLEAN.
BUT TO HAVE THESE RIDICULOUS
REGULATIONS AROUND THANKSGIVING
WHEN THE POLITICIANS ARE NOT
FOLLOWING THEM THEMSELVES, IT IS
KIND OF LIKE HAVING A FAT
TRAINER.
WHY AM I TAKING YOUR ADVICE IF
YOU ARE NOT TAKING YOUR OWN
ADVICE?
>> Greg: HE MIGHT BE
BIG-BONED.
A HEFTY TRAINER.
DON’T FAT SHAMED THE TRAINERS.
>> Jesse: SORRY, GREG.
I APOLOGIZE.
>> Juan: I UNDERSTAND THAT
PEOPLE DO NOT WANT TO HAVE THE
GOVERNMENT TELLING THEM WHAT TO
DO.
>> Kennedy: HEAR, HEAR.
>> Juan: THE LIBERTARIAN OVER
HERE.
BUT I THINK THAT THERE IS A
POINT WHERE INDIVIDUAL ACTIONS
IMPACT THE SAFETY OF US ALL.
AND IN EASIEST EXAMPLE WOULD BE
SPEEDING.
OBVIOUSLY YOU CAN’T DRIVE YOUR
CAR AS FAST AS YOU MIGHT WANT
TO, BECAUSE THAT IMPACTS OTHER
PEOPLE YOU COULD CRASH AND OTHER
PEOPLE, HURT YOURSELF, KILL
PEOPLE, AND THE LIKE.
THESE DAYS YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO SMOKE INDOORS.
IT CERTAINLY CAN’T SMOKE ON AN
AIRPLANE.
THAT’S BECAUSE OF US AMERICANS
AS A FAMILY LOOKING OUT FOR EACH
OTHER.
AND I THINK IN THIS WAY WE HAVE
TO START TO THINK MORE OPENLY
ABOUT WHY THESE REGULATIONS ARE
IN PLACE.
IT IS NOT ABOUT DEMOCRATS.
TODAY WE HAD THREE OR FOUR
COREPUBLICAN GOVERNORS SAY I AM
GOING TO IMPOSE SOME LIMITS,
WHETHER IT IS MASKS OR OTHER
LIMITS IN TERMS OF GATHERING, SO
YOU ARE SEEING IT MOVING AWAY
FROM THE TRUMP-STEEL HAND.
NOW I THINK IT IS THE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS SAYING THE REASON WE
ARE DOING THIS IS NOT JUST
BECAUSE OF FEAR, IT IS THE
INCREASE OF INFECTION AND A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE HOSPITALIZED
AND THE HOSPITALS ARE REACHING
CAPACITY IN TERMS OF DEALING
WITH THIS AND IT IS A LAGGING
INDICATOR, BUT WE SEE AN
INCREASE IN DEATHS.
THAT IS A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
FOR AMERICA, NOT REPUBLICAN OR
DEMOCRAT, BUT FOR US ALL.
>> Greg: I THINK HOSPITAL
CAPACITY IS NOWHERE NEAR THAT,